you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme the divers in
thailand finding a new lease of life for
discarded fishing gear
littering our oceans the second extreme
e-race takes place this weekend in
senegal
i'll be speaking to british driver jamie
chadwick about how the event is raising
awareness of climate change
and music legend gary newman on the
climate inspiration
behind his latest album
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
well coming up the new app
aiming to use citizen scientists to
track insect
populations but we're starting today
looking at ghost
nets that's the term for fishing
equipment lost or discarded
in the sea and it's a growing problem up
to a million tons of abandoned fishing
nets enter the world's oceans
every year the plastic-based gear can
take up to 600 years to break down
shedding microplastics as it degrades
and it makes up half of the world's
largest collection of marine
debris floating in the pacific ocean
over 150 000 seals and cetaceans that's
whales dolphins and porpoises
are estimated to be killed annually by
lost fishing equipment
along with thousands of seabirds turtles
and sharks
but now divers in thailand are trying to
turn the problem of discarded gear
into a solution as our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins reports
[Applause]
these divers in thailand are on a
mission
park cleanup park rescue
and this is their target the thousands
of tons of
old fishing nets dubbed ghost nets
littering the ocean
every year ghostness are actually really
dangerous because once they are
fallen into the ocean they can stay
afloat for decades
so either marine anymore will be
entrapped there
or they will digest those nets
discarded fishing gear is one of the
deadliest forms of ocean plastic
pollution
harming 66 of marine mammal species
the divers collect and measure the ghost
nets
47 fishing communities across thailand
are doing the same this is a huge
problem we swam about
10 minutes and we've already found our
first net and around
50 000 small fishermen carry these alone
in thailand
the amount that are littering the ocean
floor is still unknown
back on the land the nets are separated
and cleaned
so what we can see here is clearly a
dead individual there's no animal left
inside
they're then recycled some turned into
covered visors
but they keep on mounting up we have the
band-aid solution at the beginning which
is to actively remove the nets
that deals with the symptom it prevents
further things from getting entangled
the finding the source of the problem is
another matter entirely but they're not
giving up
scientists and campaigners will log
every ghost net they
spot in the hope they finally rid the
sea
of this deadly rubbish siobhan robbins
sky news
thailand a new campaign has been
launched to encourage small businesses
to cut their emissions to help the uk
reach its net zero goal by 2050. they're
being asked to make small changes such
as switching to
energy-saving light bulbs as well as
bigger moves
such as investing in electric vehicles
our political correspondent joe pike
explains more well the reason the
government are focusing on the uk small
businesses is because they employ
about 60 of the uk workforce and
contribute 2.2
trillion pounds to the economy this
seems to be an attempt
by government ministers to try and help
smaller businesses and
micro businesses understand their
emissions and start to put
together a plan to tackle them small
practical steps at first
they mention using energy saving light
bulbs
more sustainable forms as transport and
also think about
more sustainable forms of packaging if
companies are producing
some form of product now you might think
towards the end of a pandemic
many businesses will just be trying to
survive
trying to break even let alone think
about moving towards net zero but
actually
the federation of small businesses has
said that this is a moment
to look to the future and now is the
time to start taking the first steps
towards net zero in today's other
climate news
from next week drivers of high polluting
cars will have to pay eight pounds to
travel into the centre of birmingham
the launch of the clean air zone will
see older vehicles that don't meet
emission standards
charged for driving within certain areas
it's estimated around 900 people in
birmingham
die early each year from air pollution
the rac is developing new technology to
help out of charge
electric cars the firm's working with
specialist engineers to fit its patrol
vans with lightweight electric charges
capable of getting flat evs back up and
running
it hopes to have 200 of its fans
equipped with the chargers
by the end of this year sailors taking
part in tomorrow's
ocean race europe will collect data on
climate change as they compete
the teams will carry scientific
equipment on board take samples of
microplastics
measure co2 levels and water
temperatures
the data will help scientists study the
impact humans had on the seas
drivers are being asked to count bugs to
help scientists understand the
uk's insect population the charity bug
life has launched a new app which
lets users record the number of bugs
squashed on their car number plate after
going on a journey
there's evidence that insects are
declining because of habitat loss
and pesticides and the tree council has
launched a campaign
urging people to look after their
hedgerows which they say are vital in
the fight against climate change
it's estimated every year a hedgerow can
absorb the carbon produced by a car
traveling over 1 000 kilometers
now the second race in the new
international extreme e-racing series is
taking place this weekend
it's all about using electric suv racing
to try and improve innovations in
electric car technology
and the five remote race locations have
been chosen to highlight the impacts
of climate change and human interference
and to support local community projects
now this weekend's race is in senegal
where the spectacular atlantic coastline
is threatened
by the impact of warming oceans and sea
level rises
well joining me now from black rose is
jamie chadwick who's a driver
for the veloce team welcome to you
so how does driving on the senegalese
coast
in an electric car how different is that
to what you're used to
it's very different to anything i'm used
to i come from a circuit racing world so
um yeah just the off-road element is a
big difference for me but
yeah to be racing along the ocean front
in senegal is
something completely new for me
especially so
it's really exciting and yeah i'm really
enjoying the challenge and why are you
racing there in senegal what issues are
you trying to highlight
yeah i mean i quite a few issues um that
we've noticed here in in terminal
obviously the sea levels rising the
warming pollution
and also the plastic pollution is
something that has become even more
noticeable ever since we've been here so
um yeah it's
great that we can come to these
locations educate where we can but also
hopefully put on a spectacular motorist
and what inspired you to get involved in
the first place
um i think from my point of view um like
i said as a racing driver we never
really had the opportunity to kind of
make change or use our platform for any
sort of
thing else other than the driving so to
have this opportunity to promote both
climate change and also gender equality
all the teams have
one male driver and one female driver is
something that
i'm really proud to be a part of and
it's just so much different to anything
i've done before which
is uh yeah really exciting and i think
you've
already tested out the course there in
senegal how did you find it
yeah i've not actually been on track yet
i'm out this afternoon so i'll let you
know
i've got it on the background now and it
looks to be an amazing track you know
we're going right down the oceanfront
um over a lot of dunes and it looks
spectacular so i'm really looking
forward to it
jamie chadwick we appreciate your time
thanks very much
thank you
now music can be a powerful force for
change and one person
hoping his latest album will make a
difference to how people see the world
is gary newman intruder looks at climate
change from the planet's point of view
expressing what he imagines the earth
must be feeling at the moment
well earlier i spoke to gary newman and
started by asking what the album
is all about the new one
takes a point of view of the the planet
itself if the planet could speak
what would it say and how would it
articulate the way that it feels
does it feel angry is it hurt
disillusioned
does it feel betrayed you know but
importantly is it fighting back
has it been fighting back for some time
and we just haven't realized it
um that's really the album in a nutshell
if you can change people's minds you you
can therefore encourage them
in a way that they may vote um in the
way they talk to their friends which may
encourage them to think differently
and yeah and by sort of small measures
you
you create a direction you if people
vote a certain way
it it sends a very strong signal as to
what they want the future to be and what
they want their leaders to be
i want them to do and obviously you feel
inspired to
express yourself but do you think music
can make a difference in
changing people's minds what role can it
play in
influencing people well i think it can
you know i i don't know that how it's
it's like super powerful
i don't think it's that you know
certainly not the protest movement it
was
you know a few decades back i don't know
that it has a great deal of power but it
can certainly
have some bring some bearing it can
bring some interest to and i've been
talking about intruder now for
months you know particularly keen in the
last few weeks or so and all i'm talking
about is
climate change so even people that don't
like the album don't like me
you know we're still making that noise
we're doing it now
you know we're talking about something
that people need to be talking about
and that's a good thing you know even if
the album itself isn't
you know sort of dies of death and
nobody buys it you know the fact that
we're here talking about it
is worthwhile it was worth making it for
this alone
that's it for today's show but you can
get your climate fix over the weekend
with our podcast
and on this week's episode we look at
how court cases can be used
to fight climate change that's on
climate cast and it's available wherever
you normally get your podcast from
and on our weekly digital show we go
behind the scenes of adam parsons
investigation
into poland's coal pollution dilemma
that's available on sky news social
channels our app
and our website thanks for watching
we're taking a break at the start of
next week but we'll be back at our usual
time on thursday see you then